SERIOUSLY DISCUSSED IS AS,
PRESIDENT BIDEN NOTES TONIGHT,
NOT SOMETHING YOU HAVE REALLY
SEEN SINCE THE 1960s.
>> KAITLAN COLLINS, APPRECIATE
IT.
ACCORDING TO UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT
SAYING HIS COUNTRY'S FORCES HAVE
TAKEN BACK 500 SQUARE KILOMETERS
OF TERRITORY IN THE KHERSON
REGION, ALL IN LESS THAN A WEEK
LE ALSO SAID THEY'VE SEEN
SUCCESS IN THE EASTERN DIRECTION
AND THE DAY WILL COME WHEN THEY
TALK ABOUT THE, QUOTE,
LIBERATION OF CRIMEA.
THIS COMES AS RUSSIAN FORCES
ABANDON MANY OF THEIR POSITIONS
IN THE SOUTH WITH THEM BEING
BATTER ODD TONIGHT FRONT LINES
AND MORALE SLIPPING.
MELISSA BELL HAS A REPORT FROM
WAGNER GROUP, A MERCENARY
ORGANIZATION AIDING IN THE WAR
AGAINST UKRAINE.
WE HAVE TO WARN SOME OF THE
IMAGES YOU'LL SEE ARE
DISTURBING.
>> Reporter: THE CHAOS OF
UKRAINE'S FRONT LINES THROUGH
THE EYES OF A WAGNER MERCENARY.
>> LEGS, GUTS, ARMS, BOYS.
IT'S ALMOST TOUGH.
>> Reporter: A VIDEO SHARED
EXCLUSIVELY WITH CNN BY A MEMBER
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN'S SO-CALLED
PRIVATE ARMY.
ONE OF THOSE WHO HAS SEEN
ENOUGH.
>> I'M SORRY, BRO, I'M SORRY.
>> Reporter: A FAR CRY FROM THE
SLICK PROPAGANDA USED BY WAGNER
TO ENTICE RECRUITS TO THE
DEPLETED RUSSIAN FRONT LINES.
LONG KEPT IN THE SHADOWS BY
MOSCOW, THE ELITE PARAMILITARY
GROUP, OR THE MUSICIANS, AS THEY
CALL THEMSELVES, NOW LIONIZED
FOR THEIR ROLE IN RUSSIA'S
SPRINGTIME VICTORIES.
LIKE THE SURRENDER OF, INITIALLY
MAKING ALL THE DIFFERENCE TO
MOSCOW, ACCORDING TO THIS FORMER
WAGNER COMMANDER.
>> Translator: WITHOUT THEIR
ACTIVE ASSISTANCE, THE RUSSIAN
ARMED FORCES WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD AT ALL.
>> Reporter: THE KREMLIN DIDN'T
RESPOND TO OUR REQUEST FOR
COMMENT, BUT A MONTHS' LONG CNN
INVESTIGATION HAS FOUND WHAT THE
WAR HAS COST MOSCOW'S ELITE
FIGHTING FORCE.
ITS MEN, ITS CONFIDENCE, AND ITS
ALLURE.
THIS MAN SAYS WAGNER FIGHTERS
ARE PAID $5,000 A MONTH TO DO
THE WORK REGULAR RUSSIAN SOLDERS
CAN'T OR WON'T.
>> THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
MOTIVATION OR MONEY, RUSSIAN FOR
THE AMERICAN DOLLARS.
>> THROUGH THEIR TELEGRAM
CHANNELS AND INTERCEPTS,
UKRAINIAN INTELLIGENCE KEEPS A
WATCHFUL EYE.
MORALE WITHIN WAGNER IS LOW,
SAYS ANDRE USOF, IT WASN'T
DESIGNED TO PARTICIPATE IN A
FULL SCALE WAR.
>> Translator: THEY'RE
DISSATISFIED WITH THE OVERALL
ORGANIZATION OF THE FIGHTING,
THE INABILITY TO ORGANIZE
BATTLES.
AND OF COURSE THIS MEANS LOSSES.
>> Reporter: THIS VIDEO SHARED
WITH CNN BY UKRAINE'S DEFENSE
MINISTRY SHOWS A MERCENARY
DESPERATELY ASKING WHY THERE IS
NO BODY ARMOR FOR THEM.
>> Translator: THERE ARE NO MORE
FLAK JACKETS, NO MORE HELMETS
EITHER.
>> Reporter: OF THE ESTIMATED
5,000 WAGNER MERCENARIES SENT TO
UKRAINE, 1,500 HAVE BEEN KILLED
ACCORDING TO INTELLIGENCE
SOURCES IN KYIV.
IN RUSSIA, THAT'S MEANT
RECRUITMENT DRIVES.
FROM FRONT PAGES TO BILLBOARDS,
THE W ORCHESTRA IS WAITING FOR
YOU, SAYS THIS ONE, WITH A
NUMBER TO CALL AND, NO
EXPERIENCE NEEDED.
A RECRUITER TELLING CNN THROUGH
WHATSAPP THAT BARRING THUG RI
AND TERRORISM, SEXUAL
IMPROPRIETY, ARE ALL CRIMINAL
OFFENSES -- PERSONALLY OFFERING
CLEMENCY TO PRISONERS FOR SIX
MONTHS OF MILITARY SERVICE.
THE OLIGARCH NO LONGER DENYING
TIES TO THE GROUP THAT THE WAR
IN UKRAINE HAS BOTH EXPOSED AND
TRANSFORMED.
>> IT REALLY SHOWS THESE GUYS
ARE IN TROUBLE.
THEY REALLY DON'T HAVE PEOPLE.
THEY'RE READY TO SEND ANYONE.
THERE'S NO CRITERIA FOR
PROFESSIONALS ANYMORE.
>> Reporter: AND THAT COULD MEAN
MORE POSSIBLE WAR CRIMES,
ESPECIALLY ON THE RETREAT.
THIS VIDEO SHARED WITH CNN BY A
WAGNER SOLDIER, APPEARS TO SHOW
MERCENARIES LINING UP THE BODIES
OF DEAD UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS.
IN A CHILLING CONVERSATION, THEY
DEBATE WHETHER TO BOOBY TRAP
THEM OR SHOOT THOSE WHO COME TO
RETRIEVE THEM BEFORE REALIZING
THAT THEY'RE OUT OF AMMUNITION.
>> MELISSA BELL JOINS ME NOW
FROM POLAND.
THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY.
SINCE THE WAGNER GROUP AND THE
RUSSIAN ARMED FORCES ARE
OPERATING IN THE SAME
BATTLEFIELD, IS THERE POLITICAL
CONFLICT, DO WE KNOW, BETWEEN
WAGNER AND RUSSIA'S MILITARY
DEFENSE?
>> WE DO HAVE AN IDEA, ANDERSON,
THAT WHEN THE WAR BEGAN THERE
HAD BEEN A FALLING OUT BETWEEN
PE GROEGS AND VLADIMIR PUTIN,
THE IDEA THAT THE TWO MEN WHO
WORK VERY CLOSE.
THEY GO WAY BACK TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S ST. PETERSBURG DAY.
YOU'LL REMEMBER THAT WHEN THE
RUSSIAN ARMED FORCES STARTED TO
SEE THOSE SETBACKS IN FEBRUARY,
MARCH, RETREATED FROM AREAS LIKE
KYIV, THE IDEA THAT THAT IS WHEN
WAGNER CAME IN.
REMEMBER, ANDERSON, THAT IS WHEN
WAGNER BEGAN TO MAKE A MASSIVE
DIFFERENCE, NOT BECAUSE THE MEN
WERE THAT NUMEROUS.
SIMPLY BECAUSE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE MOST EXPERIENCED ON
THE BATTLEFIELD.
SO, YOU HAD THOSE VICTORIES,
MARIUPOL, KHERSON, ALL THOSE
VICTORIES WE SAW IN THE SPRING
THAT WERE LARGELY CREDITED TO
WAGNER BECAUSE ALTHOUGH THEY
WERE FUNCTIONING WITHIN THE
STRUCTURES OF THE RUSSIAN ARMED
FORCES, THEIR EXPERIENCES, THE
FACT THEY WERE BATTLE HARDENED
HELPED TO MAKE THE DIFFERENCE ON
THE GROUND.
THE QUESTION IS NOW WHETHER
THEY'RE CONTINUING TO ADD THAT
VALUE, ANDERSON.
>> I MEAN, HOW ARE THE
RECRUITMENT -- WAGNER'S
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS IF IN THAT
AD THEY'RE SAYING, NO EXPERIENCE
NECESSARY.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A GREAT
AD FOR THE PROFESSIONALISM OF
WAGNER THUGS.
>> IT ISN'T JUST THEY LOST 1,500
MEN, WE HEAR, ON THE GROUND.
BUT ALSO THEY'VE HAD TO RECRUIT
NOT JUST THE BATTLE HARDENED
EXPERIENCED MEN THEY SOUGHT FROM
THEIR THEATERS IN ACTION IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR.
BUT THEY'VE FILLED THEIR RANKS
WITH PEOPLE WHO AREN'T DOING
THAT SAME SORT OF FIGHTING.
THAT HAS MADE A MASSIVE
DIFFERENCE, THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE ON THE GROUND.
THEY SIMPLY AREN'T WHAT THEY
WERE WHEN THIS WAR BEGAN.
AS YOU HEARD THEN, THEY ARE NOT
THE FIGHTING FORCE THAT WAS
MEANT TO BE FUNCTIONING INSIDE A
FULL-SCALE WAR.
AND UKRAINE, IT TURNS OUT, HAS
TAKEN ITS TOLL ON WAGNER ITSELF.
THERE ARE THE TWO RECRUITING
DRIVES.
ONE IS FROM THE RUSSIAN STATE.
IT IS OBLIGATORY.
THE MONEY IS LESS THAN WITHIN
WAGNER.
WAGNER IS VOLUNTARY.
THEY PAY MORE.
WHAT THEY'RE FINDING IS THAT IT
IS NOT THAT MANY RUSSIANS
CHOOSING TO SIGN UP, HENCE THE
RECRUITMENT DRIVES IN THE
RUSSIAN PRISONS.
REMEMBER, ANDERSON, THIS MATTERS
ON THE FIELD NOT JUST BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS TH